über das wochenende haben sich die
bestätigten corona fälle in deutschland
etwa verdreifacht die verunsicherung in
der bevölkerung ist spürbar auch weil
sich die gefährlichkeit des virus noch
nicht einschätzen ist ist deutschland
gut aufgestellt im kampf gegen das virus
wie belastbar ist unser
gesundheitssystem darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit meinen gästen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und zu unter den
linden heute zum thema corona virus in
deutschland
ich freue mich sehr auf meine gäste bei
uns ist professor alexander kekulé
virologe an der universität in halle und
bei uns ist professor karl lauterbach
spd politiker und
gesundheitswissenschaftler ja schön dass
sie dabei sind
heute hat ja gesundheitsminister jens
spahn zusammen mit experten unter
anderem des robert koch instituts über
die aktuelle lage zum corona virus in
deutschland informiert und das risiko
für uns alle ist auf mäßig hochgestuft
worden
schauen wir doch mal was der minister
allgemein heute zur situation gesagt hat
seit wochen überschlagen sich die
meldungen über das neue corona virus
immer mehr menschen erkranken auf der
welt in europa und auch hier bei uns in
deutschland und das virus kommt auch
eben bei uns oder ist angekommen in
europa und in deutschland ich habe
letzte woche gesagt wir sind am beginn
einer pandemie offensichtlich weltweit
aber im ball mit auch eine epidemie hier
bei uns in deutschland
das macht vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern
angst und sorge und das kann ich gut
verstehen denn im gegensatz zu anderen
erkrankungen haben wir alle hat die
bevölkerung die bürgerinnen und bürger
mit diesen neuer mit dieser neuen
atemwegserkrankung aus china keine
erfahrung
wir kennen sie nicht die bürgerinnen und
bürger kennen die nachricht dass das
virus immer näher kommt sie kennen die
bilder von menschen in china
in schutzanzügen zu hören und lesen
widersprüchliche warnung von teilweise
jedenfalls zweifelhaften experten
das verunsichert und genau deshalb sind
wir heute hier genau deshalb sind wir
auch heute hier und wollen darüber
sprechen herr kekulé sich bei waren ja
die experten heute darum bemüht so ein
wenig der history entgegenzuwirken
wie gehen sie ganz persönlich eigentlich
damit um auf der einen seite aufzuklären
aber auf der anderen seite auch keine
panik in der bevölkerung schüren zu
wollen
für mich ist es ein vorhersehbares
ereignis so weit gewesen ich hatte ja
schon im januar angekündigt dass das zu
uns kommen wird und für mich selber ist
es deshalb keinen grund sich aufzuregen
wir haben es mit einem erreger zu tun
der so ähnlich wie die grippe aber nicht
ganz so stark über leicht übertragbar
wie die grippe ist und der den nachteil
hat dass er tatsächlich gefährlicher als
die grippe ist das muss man der stelle
betonen
ich glaube aber trotzdem dass wir wenn
wir das richtige tun auch jetzt noch in
deutschland die chance haben das zu
bekämpfen darum sehe ich das eigentlich
bisher gelassen wie wir das richtige tun
aber sprechen wir im laufe der sendung
herr lauterbach
sie sind ja politiker und epidemiologe
das heißt können uns in beiden fragen
helfen am freitag gab es 53 bestätigte
fälle
über das wochenende hat sich das ganze
verdreifacht wie ist denn dieser anstieg
aus ihrer sicht zu bewerten
also von dem was wir bisher wissen wir
haben ja auf der grundlage der daten
also keine richtige gute erkenntnis aber
man erwartet also sagen wir mal dass ich
in einer generation der übertragung das
sind in der regel so 45 tage so schnell
geht das
die zahl also verdoppelt wenn der wenn
die übertragungsrate 2 ist für jeden
infizierten das ist ungefähr jetzt die
übertragungsrate über den daumen gepeilt
das weiß man nicht ganz genau aber somit
würde man erwarten dass ich das
tatsächlich in vier tagen verdoppelt
genau das sehen will und also wenn also
hochrechnen
dann kommt man so ähnlich also auf
zahlen wie man sie wenn man zurück
rechnet in china gesehen hat oder in
italien auch gesehen hat zumindest genau
wie kohl ist es keine überraschung
und ich habe auch im januar eben ihre
weniger das gleiche gesagt nein also
einschätzung also in soll er hier kann
experten statt oder was auch immer sein
wie ein bisschen anderer marken und zwar
ich glaube dass die über die also im
ansteckungsgefahr balkon mindestens so
riße beide grippe also nicht geringer
weil wenn ich jetzt bei der normalen
grippe hochrechnet dann eher wichtig
immer ein 1,3 neue fälle für jeden der
schon infiziert ist und bei caro kona
glauben viele experten auch also an da
universität wo ich gewesen bin ich bin
ab dann der gastprofessoren bin der
woche da gewesen ich glaube das könnte
hochgehen auf bis zu 2,3 oder so etwas
nicht ganz so hoch ist ist es so das
sagen weil ich das also sehr gefährlich
findet was jetzt passiert dass ich wird
dass wir uns ungefähr so wie folgt die
schaden das ist etwas ansteckender als
die grippe aber deutlich gefährlicher so
über das ungefähr über den daumen
gepeilt sehen also wir haben schon grund
hier alles zu tun um das zu beherrschen
müssten dann nicht eigentlich noch mehr
menschen in der bevölkerung getestet
werden
ist es nicht vielleicht so dass wir dann
menschen mit ähnlichen symptomen direkt
testen müssen
das ist ein vorschlag den ich vor über
drei wochen gemacht habe leider bis
dahin ohne erfolg das müssen sie die
kollegen am robert koch institut und im
gesundheitsministerium fragen aber ich
hatte vorgeschlagen dass wir jeden und
bedrängen nach wie vor darauf dass wir
jeden der eine der schwere grippeartige
symptome zeigt natürlich nicht jeden der
bisschen husten sondern jeden der
schwere symptome zeigt immer parallel
auch auf corona virus testen weil wir
dadurch in der lage sind kleine
infektionsketten die da auftreten am
anfang so frühzeitig zu erkennen dass
wir diese ketten durch isolierung durch
quarantäne durch nachverfolgung mit
unseren gesundheitsbehörden tatsächlich
wieder einfangen können bevor es einen
flächen artigen ausbruch gibt es ist in
berlin heute der erste fall aufgetreten
der bestätigt wurde natürlich heißt es
nicht dass es der erste fall ist und
dieser fall ist zumindest habe ich das
jetzt so gerichtet bekommen so aufgeht
so entstanden dass man oder so entdeckt
worden dass man tatsächlich an der
klinik wo der gekommen ist das gemacht
hat das ist seit wochen empfehle was
nicht vom robert koch institut empfohlen
wurde nämlich man hat den parallel
obwohl der grippe symptome hat einfach
mal so auf corona virus getestet
und der war positiv so dass man hier
eine infektionskette weil die berliner
behörden da sehr gut waren tatsächlich
gefunden hat das ist natürlich eine
nadel im heuhaufen
ich fürchte dass noch ein paar mehr hier
hatten sie das an hellwach
wer sich genau so
das tatsächlich so hier gibt es zwei
gründe das zu tun zum einen also man
kann tatsächlich die normale grippe und
corona gleichzeitig haben das ist eine
sehr hohe sterblichkeit also dass also
hat er also dass das richtig gefährlich
und das heißt dann sollte man sich jetzt
noch gegen grippe impfen lassen ja also
im clip gegen grippe impfen lassen ist
immer noch sinnvoll
selbstverständlich wobei ich sage mal
also diese kekulé hatte hier auf das
doppelte abgehoben
und da sage ich für sinnvoll ich hatte
sinnvoll war es sinnvoll ist sowohl wenn
ich die grippe bestätigt bekommen als
auch also wenn ich sozusagen nur den
verdacht habe ich würde beides testen
bei begründetem grippe verdacht würde
ich immer war das testen da so hatte ich
ihren vorstellungen standen als richtig
warum passiert das denn dann nicht also
das also sind man muss ja nach vorne
blicken in dem sinn aber sie können sagt
wir können also ich würde grundsätzlich
jetzt bei grippe verdacht würde ich
immer die opfer testung empfehlen
das sage ich also in zustimmung so und
zwar aus zwei gründen hat man kann
beides haben das dann richtig gefährlich
das ist gar keine frage
und man kann also man könnte zum
beispiel eine ganze zeit machen schon
einer seiner sucht klinische corona
infektionen haben also dass man noch
keine symptome hat man aber schon länger
dann ist man aber für die grippe sogar
anfälliger und wenn man dann war das
bekommt hat unruhig darf ich ganz und
daher würde ich aus dem grunde machen
und ich bin selten aber als es dann sehr
gefährlich und zum zweiten also nicht
dass einer taste ist auch der verdacht
ganz grundsätzlich für das andere davon
daher will ich das immer kombiniert
machen dass also da stimme ich ihnen
sogar zu das heißt sie würden der
bevölkerung raten darauf zu drängen wenn
man jetzt richtige grippe symptome und
nicht bei einem kleinen schnupfen
sondern weil wirklich richtig
dezidierten grippesymptomen darauf zu
drängen
ein test ich würde gar nicht an die
bevölkerung geben sondern es würde
erreichen wenn die ärzte das wissen ja
weil für mich ist es so wissen sie bei
diesem corona virus ich sehe das
natürlich sehr nüchtern epidemiologisch
ja da ist es so wir haben ungefähr einen
von zehn der so schwer krank ist dass er
ins krankenhaus muss 80 haben eigentlich
gar keine schlimmen symptome das kann
man nicht oft genug betonen aber einer
von zehn muss wirklich ins krankenhaus
und vielleicht einer von zwanzig dann
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
wenn sie jeden überhaupt nur der ins
krankenhaus muss wirklich konsequent
dann testen würden dann würden sie
statistisch und bei dem zehnten
patienten mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
eine infektionskette feststellen und
zehn das ist etwas damit können unsere
gesundheitsbehörden in deutschland
umgehen im iran markus ein problem sein
wir kriegen das hin
wir kriegen es aber nicht hin wenn wir
200 haben also 200 nachzuverfolgen ist
fast unmöglich und darum sage ich das
münchner beispiel wo in einem
autozulieferer diese infektionskette
komplette identifiziert und durch
quarantäne und isolation beendet wurde
das zeigt uns doch eigentlich wenn wir
ganz früh die fälle erkennen dann können
wir das machen was die epidemiologen
stepping out nennen also das austreten
wie eine glimmende zigarette bevor sie
den waldbrand verursacht münchen hat
gezeigt dass wir das können und darum
müssen wir diese einzelnen
infektionsketten ganz früh
identifizieren und deshalb diese tests
machen
das stimmt also dem stimme ich auch zu
also die es geht jetzt nur darum zeit zu
gewinnen
mehr ist nicht drin war tatsächlich wird
nach von allem was wir wissen wird sich
über die nächsten zwei jahre ein großer
teil der bevölkerung infizieren
es geht nur darum zeit zu gehen muss
zeit gewinnen ist die grippesaison
abgeklungen ist dass ich da sagen wir
eine doppelbelastung des systems habe
oder keine doppel infizierten und das
wird auch im sommer also nicht
ausschlafen komplett sondern das
weitergeben kommt dann hart zurückgehen
wird in diesem jahr weiter gehen als wir
dagegen ganz klar es wird nicht mehr so
viele fälle geben aber wir haben also
jetzt sagen wir jetzt sprechen dass bis
als politiker sondern wissenschaftler
das ist im sommer weg ist in dem sinne
aber ist jetzt vorbei das hat was der
alptraum ist vorbei da ist
ausgeschlossen
und das geht im sommer weitesten aber
dann weniger fälle und das kommt dann
relativ hart zurück im nächsten herbst
hat das teil der bevölkerung wird gar
nicht spüren dass sie tatsächlich
infiziert worden sie dass hinter jedem
zehnten also bei jedem zehnten ist es
ausgeschlossen dass er es nicht bemerkt
weil musste hat so stark gelobt und
beiden älteren menschen ist die quote
fiel höher
also von daher also ist es auch nicht
denkbar wird nicht es wird nicht so sein
dass wir im sommer keine fälle mehr
mitbekommen sondern dass wir zu sagen
aber mir ist um einen anhaltspunkt dass
das jetzt früh sage ich ja mal so
einzudämmen dass ich zeit gewinne und
über diese
nochmal gut wegkomme um viel in die
nächste saison zu schieben wurde dann
auch wieder besser vorbereitet sind wo
wir dann möglicherweise auch schon näher
an einer impfung sind wir werden dann
auch noch keine impfung haben aber ist
sie natürlich näher dran
das ist sehr wertvoll und daher würde
ich jetzt auch die verdachtsfälle
ausgesprochen aggressiv verfolgen weil
jeder kleinen epidemie die ich
verhindere wie zum beispiel wenn es
jetzt gelungen wer heinsberg zu
verhindern
er macht viel unterschied das macht viel
aus und das ganze geht ja exponentiell
wächst sozusagen also einfach
ausgedrückt 24 8 16 32 c zu hoch in dem
sinne ist das der grund warum sie jetzt
die absage von großveranstaltungen
gefordert haben wir ja anders ja als
gesundheitsminister sparen sagt es muss
auf kommunaler ebene war reiner zufall
ich bin also hier ist nicht mal also ich
bin jetzt nicht hier aussparen kritik
oder so das können sie aber in der in
der summe ist es so also bei
großveranstaltungen werde im moment
besonders vorsichtig wenn das zu sagen
wir internationale gäste betrifft
das ist klar dann habe ich kein park an
das hat 23 nach dem essen beispiel als
sonst wäre ich relativ also klar dabei
oder hort zum beispiel hat der spiegel
seiner hauptstadt party abgesagt das war
nicht großartig kein gutes zeichen das
ist genau richtig so der clevere sache
gewesen absolut richtig was soll man
feiern derweil die lage sich so
entwickelt und also ich würde bei
großveranstaltungen versuchen zu mehr
absagen zu kommen weil damit geht uns
nichts verloren
wir kriegen die sache aber jetzt so ein
bisschen besser in den griff und das
wird uns zeit kaufen um aus der saison
raus zu kommen wo das richtig riskantes
wegen der witterung wegen der noch
laufenden grippeepidemie und auch der
aufbau von ressourcen also das was
besser dann in griff bekommen also dass
man wir sind ja noch nicht in einer
pandemie
sonst hätten wir ganz anders also wir
sind in einer epidemie wir sind nicht in
der pandemie aber wenn wir in einer
pandemie kommen dann sind ja ganz andere
maßnahmen notwendig und das muss man
vorbereiten können und das zu gewinnen
ist ganz toll aber würden sie sagen es
ist schon der richtige weg dass es von
fall zu fall auf kommunaler ebene
entschieden wird oder gibt es da
also man könnte es auch sich so
vorstellen also man könnte sich
vorstellen dass den kommunen die ja
rechtlich also wenn es keine pandemie
ist berechtigt dazu in der lage und sind
noch zuständig war
bei einer panne gelten ganz andere
regeln gelten andere gesetze
das ist daher sind wir nicht da ist der
unterschied zwischen epidemie und fannie
mae das klingt das sehr ähnlich der
unterschied ist aber groß und großer
unterschied was die zuständigkeiten
angeht wenn eine pandemie da ist dann
hat der bund durchgriffsrechte die also
das würden sie als drakonisch bezeichnen
was aber die sind dann da die sind jetzt
nicht da jetzt kann ich aber auch die
kommunen zugehen und kann den kommunen
sagen was man auf freunde wenn wir eine
pandemie hier verhindern wollen wo ihr
das größte interesse daran haben ist
dann lass es uns auch so machen das wäre
eine denkbare sache also ich kann noch
ergänzen dass mir das überhaupt nicht
ausreicht was der entschlossen
beschlossen wurde vom krisenstab die
empfehlung ist ja so auf die sie
angesprochen haben dass die kommunen
gemeinsam mit den veranstaltern von fall
zu fall überlegen sollen
ob eine veranstaltung abgesagt wird oder
nicht meines erachtens sind damit völlig
überfordert selbst fachleute wenn sie es
gut meinen sind brauchen relativ lange
um überhaupt einen konsens zu finden und
die empfehlung aus aus berlin ist ja
jetzt die gewesen dass die kommunen
überlegen sollen wie viele ausländische
gäste kommen und wie eng kommen sich die
gäste und dann wurde als beispiel
genannt eine tanzveranstaltung seit zum
beispiel gefährlich da muss ich jetzt
sagen als jemand der in münchen lebt
wenn sie mal im stadion waren und der fc
bayern da spielt dann ist das was in der
für in der ultra kurve sehen auch so was
ähnliches wie die tanzveranstaltung
gefallen sich bei jedem tor so um die
arme gegenseitig kommen auch schon gut
bewusst nicht hin zu dem stadion
sie können das ist das wesen der
großveranstaltung sie können weder sagen
wie die gäste sich verhalten vorher noch
wer kommt und dann zu sagen da
entscheidet dass man von fall zu fall
das ist leider wieder so ein fall wo man
das dann auf diejenigen abwälzt die
damit überfordert sind die kommunalen
gesundheitsbehörden die sowieso kaum
personal haben und ich meine da hätte
ganz klar die ansage von oben kommen
müssen großveranstaltungen werden
abgesagt und ich bin ja sogar der
meinung dass man über darüber nachdenken
muss ob man für eine zeit jetzt wo wir
nicht wissen was im land los ist
kindergärten schließt
kitas schließt und auch die schulen eine
weile zu macht um ein bild von dem
aktuellen zustand zu bekommen und hus
fälle geben würden sie jetzt soll ich
jetzt das sind ja schon drastische
maßnahme würden sie so was jetzt in
erwägung sich würde ich nenne das ich
nenne das corona ferien ja wir hatten
die situation schnell sehen sie mal so
wir hatten jetzt wir haben jetzt eine
woche lang in vielen bundesländern meine
ich diese fasst diese faschingsferien
oder skiferien ich weiß nicht ob die
bundesweit waren und jetzt kommen zum
beispiel in bayern wo meine kinder in
kindergarten und die schule gehen kommen
jetzt zehntausende von urlaubern aus
norditalien vom skifahren zurück aus
einem angrenzenden risikogebiet die
lässt man jetzt erstmal alles schön in
die schule gehen und schaut zu ob sich
da was entwickelt oder nicht ich hätte
mir als epidemiologe ich bin ja nicht
jemand der polit politisch oder
wirtschaftlich denken muss ich hätte als
epidemiologe gesagt nee belassen die
schulen jetzt mal zwei wochen zu und
schauen mal bei denen die zurückkommen
wer krank wird herr präsident ich weiß
dass wenn man aus einem risikogebiet
jetzt kommt dass man zu hause bleiben
soll was wirklich für erforderlich
halten gleich kitas und ja ich würde ich
würde als wenn sie es ist natürlich so
wenn sie den arzt fragen kriegen sie
eine medizin verschrieben und hier aus
ärztlicher sicht ist es so das wäre das
richtige mittel aber ich sage auch dazu
ich bin ganz glücklich dass ich kein
politiker bin der verantwortung tragen
muss der natürlich auch zum beispiel die
wirtschaftlichen aspekte mit
berücksichtigen muss dass muss man sich
dann überlegen was ist wirtschaftlich
schlimmer ich sage aber der
kollateralschaden einer solchen pandemie
da sind wir definitiv wahrscheinlich
schon drin uns die frage wann die whu
das erklärt der kollateralschaden einer
solchen situation ist natürlich enorm
wenn sie jetzt daran denken dass reisen
abgesagt werden dass das dass die
verunsicherung der bevölkerung da ist
dass leute hamsterkäufe machen und
ähnliches da sind wir schon in einer
situation wo man perspektivisch sich
fragen muss ist es schlimmer wenn ich
jetzt für 14 tage lang so eine art pause
so eine art sicherheitspolster einbau
oder ist es schlimmer wenn ich die sache
weiter laufen lassen und dann
möglicherweise in einem monat einen
zustand hat er auch unsere kliniken
überfahren
die haspa frage der verhältnismäßigkeit
das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren
wie sieht das als politiker einschätzen
also ich hatte vor
ich glaube von der woche oder so hatte
ich getwittert was auch viele
journalisten gesehen habe dass ich jetzt
ein schwerpunkt darauf setzen würde
ich war eine empfehlung quasi kinder zu
testen
weil wir das ist wir wissen wenig über
kinder also wissen dass kinder nicht
schwer erkranken kurz verdankt also so
toll dass die kinder aber wir wissen
nicht wie viele kinder infiziert sind
und wissen auch nicht gut wie stark also
einmal kinder verbreiten
meine vermutung wäre folgen das war
wirklich auch ihre meinung interessieren
ich glaube dass kinder sozusagen sehr
wenig symptome entwickeln aber stark
verbreiten einfach ausgedrückt das wäre
meine vermutung als ich also entweder
als wissenschaftler gesprochen nicht als
politiker
was mache ich da raus ich hätte daher um
die frage beantworten zu können mache
ich die schulen jetzt erst mal dicht
corona ferien um das zu verhindern hätte
ich in der letzten woche wo die ferien
war karneval ferienspielen und so weiter
und so fort
hätte ich viel getestet um ein bild zu
bekommen wie viele kinder sind hier
infiziert wie sowieso ohne anlass kinder
diesem treffen auch ist im testen genau
ganz genau ich hätte genauso wie es
gerade sagen ich hab das symptom feier
kinder sozusagen einer stichprobe
unterzogen und zwar hätte ich das so
ausgerichtet dass ich kann aus der samen
der art und weise wie ich so eine
stichprobe auswählen wo ich die kinder
finde wie viele ich habe kann ich dann
mit einer spitze stimmten statistik gar
nicht genau ausrechnen wie hoch ist
wahrscheinlich der prozentsatz der
kinder dies hat und in welcher
altersgruppe
ich muss es genau wissen muss ich genau
gut verteilen ich muss dazu sagen dass
wir genau belegen ich muss also sagen
ein schluss sozusagen genau aus also
ausgeben wie die kinder also welche
kinder sind dann kann ich davon
hochrechnen wie viele kinder habe ich
und davon hätte ich das ab er ihnen mag
da haben sie nicht die sorge dass das
bei eltern so ankommen so das ist
vielleicht eltern ein außerdem wenn ich
den eltern gegenüber habe selbst vertrat
sind ihre tochter und so wenn ich also
wenn den eltern jetzt mitgeteilt hat wir
machen ja eine vorsichtsmaßnahme und
schauen mal in einer studie die für uns
alle wichtig ist wie also ist die
immunität der kindern wie viele kinder
haben müssen wir überlegen das ist ja
ein rachenabstrich ich nehme ja hier
nicht groß also die kinder wenn ja nicht
verletzt oder so sondern das ist ja ein
rachenabstrich da ein bisschen
vorsichtiger gemacht mit den kindern
passiert ja nix und da ja also und dann
hätten wir jetzt eine gute idee davon
also wie viele kinder kommen denn jetzt
zurück die infektionen haben
ich vermute weil ich ein optimist bin
das ist nicht so viele kinder sind die
betroffenen sind dann daher bin ich also
da bist ein anderer meinung ich würde
also daher die schulen noch nicht
schließen aber ich würde mich um ganz
ehrlich zu sein das hätte ich auch von
einer woche schon also ich hätte in der
letzten woche bevor einfach ausgedrückt
bevor die kinder zurück kommen hätte ich
mir ein bild davon gemacht wie viele
kinder sind positiv das haben wir jetzt
aber nicht gemacht
lauterbach es ist natürlich so wie die
diese kann kann auch 1 ergänzen es ist
so dass wir wissen dass bei allen durch
atemwegs aber einen atemwegserkrankungen
die so ähnlich übertragen werden wie das
coroner virus also auch so ähnlich wie
die grippe bei all diesen erkrankungen
ist es immer und überall auf der welt so
dass kindertagesstätten wie ein
durchlauferhitzer sind weil die kinder
sich einfach viel näher kommen
wir wissen auch dass bei diesen
letztlich durch tröpfcheninfektionen
übertragenen erkrankungen ein großteil
dann doch über schmierinfektion also
über unmittelbare kontakte stattfindet
und wir wissen dass generell sowohl bei
der influenza als auch bei anderen
coronaviren diese die kindergärten immer
das problem sind darum steht in allen
pandemieplänen die wir seit jahrzehnten
gemacht haben
da steht drinnen als erstes wenn du den
eindruck hast brüllt kommt eine pandemie
macht die kindergärten und die zumindest
die grundschulen zu weil sie können
erwachsene
und wie sagen musste in den ellbogen und
gibt ja nicht mehr die hand zumindest
die kanzlerin hat das scheinbar
verstanden aber sie können das kleinen
kindern nicht sagen und deshalb ist es
eine ganz wichtige maßnahme meines
erachtens nicht sozusagen zu warten bis
der was passiert und dann entspannt
hinterher die epidemiologische
auswertung zu machen sondern ich bin da
zwar auch solchen epidemiologe aber mich
interessiert jetzt eigentlich mehr der
bevölkerungsschutz an erster stelle aber
wahrscheinlich ist die frage auch nur
lange macht man dann so einen
kindergarten zu helfen tage genau 14
tage weil das die längste
inkubationszeit ist um nach 14 tagen
wenn sie in der zeit aggressiv testen
haben sie nach 14 tagen genau das bild
was sie jetzt eingefordert habe also
genauso gibt die zwei möglichkeiten
hatte ich mache dich und teste in dieser
zeit oder ich teste vorher ich hätte
vorher getestet einfach aus dann müssen
sie jetzt eigentlich dafür seien da die
stadt gefunden aber lange rede kurzer
sinn also die sag mal dass das da die
tatsache dass wir jetzt nicht genau
wissen wie viele kinder infiziert sind
ist nicht vorteilhaft um so auszudrücken
und die bei den kindern also ist also
und denn der partner daher ist das auch
so wichtig dass man unterscheidet
zwischen der epidemie oder pandemie war
wenn die pandemie erklärt wird was er
jetzt noch nicht so weit so was
passieren kann
ganz natürlich an sie natürlich die
kindertagesstätten zu ja das ist dann
das erste was passiert aber die die also
ich glaube dass man das immer noch
machen kann also ich glaube das waren
immer noch kinder jetzt wollen man
braucht dafür nicht so viel zeit ich
hatte selbst mal ausgerichtet wie viele
kinder machen ungefähr braucht und so
und das also ist zu bewerten dass können
wir das können wir das können wir in
wenigen tagen könnten wir das also
bewerkstelligen aber sei natürlich schon
so dass wir die situation haben dass er
bislang die hauptlast bei den hausärzten
liegt und es erst jetzt im kreis
heinsberg diese zentrale anlaufstelle
gibt ist das so dass man sagen muss das
gesundheitssystem kommt so ein bisschen
an die grenzen noch nicht nein und das
sind weit weg von der grenze aus
da darf man auch keine sage ich mal
panik verbreiten
mein lieblingssatz ist aber es gibt
keinen grund zur panik weil die panik
immer grundlos ist ja aber es ist so
indem falls es wirklich so man darf dann
nicht mehr angst machen
unsere unser system ist noch lange nicht
an der grenze mit den paar fällen aber
das wesen einer exponentiellen kurve ist
eben dass sie sich sehr schnell
verdoppelt verdoppelt verdoppelt und da
ist eben absehbare ein mathematisch das
relativ schnell die grenze erreicht sein
könnte wie wir das in china gesehen
haben wir wissen inzwischen auch in
norditalien sehen zum beispiel die sind
auch nicht so viel schlechter vom
gesundheitssystem
ich meine dass die hausärzte und das da
geht es dann sozusagen ins detail der
teufel steckt hier wirklich im detail
es wird von der politik gesagt wir sind
gut vorbereitet ja im prinzip ja besser
als das ausland auch aber jetzt gehen
sie mal ganz konkret von der situation
aus dass jemand hustet und beim hausarzt
getestet werden soll der hausarzt hat
natürlich weil er ja die letzten wochen
immer gedacht hat das ist eine harmlose
erkrankung so wurde es gesagt haben so
soll es die grippe der hausarzt hat sich
jetzt nicht irgendwie massenweise
schutzmasken in den keller gelegt und
die schutzmasken die die ist die dafür
speziell geeignet sind wurden in den
letzten wochen nach china verkauft weil
hier in deutschland keiner hier gerufen
hat jetzt sind diese masken weg was soll
also der hausarzt machen er kann sich
irgendwie so einen einfachen europäische
umsetzen er kann einen rachenabstrich
machen und einschicken von der sekunde
an ist er selber risikopersonen wenn er
das gemacht hat muss er sich selber 14
tage in quarantäne setzen nach den
geltenden gesetzen und seine ganze halbe
praxis auch noch mit dann haben sie also
eine hause als weniger nachdem er hat
was wenn sie raten das ist eine
situation die man in berlin habe ich
jetzt so verstanden seit heute erkannt
hat und deshalb wird meine nach meiner
information jetzt am virchow krankenhaus
so eine art ria station eingerichtet wo
man genau so was machen kann ohne jetzt
die ganzen hausärzte dann zu verlieren
weil sobald sie kontaktperson eines
positiv getesteten natürlich dann sind
müssen sie hinterher die quarantäne
außer sie haben sich geschützt mit
diesen speziellen massnahmen die eben
nicht in jeder praxis zur verfügung
stehen und sie haben es kurz angedeutet
dieses speziellen infektionsschutz
masken
das muss man erst mal üben jagt das muss
man können das muss man so machen dass
man nicht beim anziehen sich selber
gleich kontaminiert also mit virus
beschmiert quasi das ist eine sache wo
ich nicht glaube dass das praxispersonal
in einen hausarzt praxen dass das schon
mal geübt hat
das stimmt das ist ein problem das es
kommen noch andere dazu also sozusagen
auf der anteile keine panik das klingt
aber nicht nach weg ich gehe davon aus
dass ich gehe davon aus so dass wir
nicht so viele fälle haben
daher gehe ich einfach davon aus dass
man das noch machen kann einfach
ausgedrückt was also wird trotzdem muss
ja nach vorne geblickt werden man muss
ja sagen was sache und was wird man tun
und dass du mich auch heute gerne
gekommen dass wir dankbar transportiert
die meisten hausärzte wissen nicht so
super viel über dieses spezielle wir uns
was kann ford bildungsdefizite ist weiß
er aber sagen wir wenn ich jetzt hier
hausherr zu fahren und würde sagen was
macht er denn mit dem abstrich wie kommt
er zum beispiel ins labor wo sind da zum
teil weit weg
wird das mit dem taxi geschickt und dann
kann der junge da kann der herr sich
auch sofort also isolieren das
trainerteam ist es nicht einfach wenn es
gut verpackt aber erst dass der
transport ist kein problem jahr würde
ich auch da wäre ich auch nicht ganz so
werden dass zum beispiel derjenige der
das eingepackt hat also das mit einer
verunreinigung gehabt hat dann ist das
dann ist er knüpft fordern wenn dann
fehler gemacht wird ja denn ich habe ich
sehe wie sie wissen doch selbst wie das
geschäft läuft in dem sich das mal ganz
im politischen neben den abstrich ab sie
sind selbst also mit dem auto sind in
berührung gekommen machen dann alles
dicht und so dann ist sozusagen außen so
infektionen fertig ist die laube weil es
hält sich ja wie sie genauso gut wissen
wenig das hört sich ja auf der
verpackung deutlich länger als eine
stunde
und dann wird müsste man und da sie
nicht wissen wie es gelaufen ist
wenn die hre hat gesagt wissen wir das
machen sollen ja dann passiert das nicht
ich habe ich am morgen rufen bei mir
jetzt die ganzen taxifahrer und chl
deutlich zum positiven vorhergesagt was
ich habe ja sie hat mich ja gesagt also
man sich ja ich gehe davon aus dass so
wenige fälle haben von daher gehe ich
habe ich ja jetzt was man energie müsste
die testprozedur laufen ich würd war
dass das ist nicht in jeder praxis so zu
leisten
zu glauben dass es in jeder praxis so
laufen laufen könnte wie wie notwendig
allein also sagen wir diese speziellen
masten hat nicht jedes praxis die masken
müssen sagen wir in einer art und weise
angelegt wird also ein bisschen anders
aus da ich nur sagen europa maske für
einen klaren angebot so einige somit
also finde ich auch richtig dass man für
die durchführung der tests um die
hausärzte zu schonen
und um es richtig zu gewährleisten
müsste man dafür zentren also vor ort
haben wo wenn jemand symptome hat gesagt
wird dorthin persönlich noch da oder wo
soll das vereinsgelände praxis sagen die
sich darauf spezialisiert hat zum
beispiel das kann ich locker machen kann
in der klinik sein
ich kann zum beispiel eine praxis nehmen
die dafür dann speziell ausgestattet ist
wo ich dann auch sicherstellen dass
dieses material haben dass die richtig
angeleitet sind uns weiter wenn ich vor
ort immer ein sag mal ich nenne es mein
vom zentrum der praxis oder eine klinik
oder was auch immer
ein anlauf zentrum hätte wo ich
diejenigen wo ich glaube die könnten
sagen also sozusagen dann teste und wo
es dort dann auch etwas gibt was man
sozusagen von gcp länder so good
clinical practice wo die mauer
geschrieben ist wie man es machen sie
dann kennen wir gut klar und das werden
sie auch die hausärzte fehlen das
wahrscheinlich gut weil die wollen ja
auch nicht im geworden der nicht
ausgesetzt also ähnlich wie in heinsberg
dass man eine zentrale anlaufstelle
schafft ist das denn realistisch haben
wir dafür das personal um mein leben
nicht dass das problem ist wie herr
lauterbach das richtig gesagt hat wir
müssen uns jetzt zeit kaufen um die zeit
bis zum sommer wo wir alle hoffen dass
die epidemie ein bisschen zurückgehen
wird das machen alle corona wären
eigentlich so darum hoffen wir dass
dieses virus das auch machen wird in
dieser zeit müssen wir versuchen so zu
sagen die sache zu glätten dass das
ganze nicht so viele fälle sind und dass
es sich über eine längere zeit verteilt
weil die krankenhäuser natürlich auch
nicht so viele patienten zugleich
behandeln können und da ist es einfach
so so schnell dass aus dem boden zu
stampfen das geht ja da los dass die
masken nicht da sind die
desinfektionsmittels nur zum teil nicht
mehr lieferbar selbst
universitätskliniken können die uni
desinfektionsmittel an diese
spezialmaske nicht mehr bestellen weil
die nicht mehr da sind wenn sie so ein
zentrum aufmachen müssen sie erst mal
die ausrüstung vorschlag ist erst 19
das heißt es ist so ein bisschen
zukunftsmusik wir haben folgende
situation wir haben in deutschland seit
vielen jahren das ist dann eigentlich
seit der letzten corona virus krise saß
krise von 2003 so richtig in die gänge
gekommen haben wir ganz gute
pandemiepläne aber diese pandemie pläne
sind geschrieben worden
für die grippe die sind für die
influenza- geschrieben worden
da steht zum beispiel drinnen ein
großteil der älteren leute ist immun
gegen die grippe weil dies schon mal
durchgemacht haben deshalb sollen die
älteren dann an die front gehen gute
idee bei corona hat das hatte ich
überhaupt keinen sinn im gegenteil
da steht zum beispiel drinnen
grippeimpfung für mitarbeiter wird
dringend empfohlen haben wir bei corinna
nicht und das wichtigste aus meiner
sicht
wir haben wir hätten für den fall der
grippe ja in allen bundesländern
eingelagert tamiflu und relenza die
medikamente gegen grippe die wirken hier
auch nicht das heißt was bieten sie denn
dem personal an wasser den kopf
hinhalten soll ja wer soll das denn
machen wenn er jetzt weiß und das ist
der letzte wichtige punkt bei der grippe
kenne die risikogruppen sehr genau wir
wissen ziemlich genau wer gefährdet ist
und nehmen wir da raus halten müssen bei
dieser neuen erkrankung ist es so dass
wir berichte haben wo menschen die
vorher völlig gesund waren die 30 40
jahre alt waren
diese erkrankung gekriegt haben und eine
woche später tot waren mit der ansage
verstehe ich natürlich dann auch
medizinisches personal was sagt okay ich
mache das schon aber da müsste mir
wirklich dinge an die hand geben mit
denen ich mich schützen kann
wenn wir die nicht haben funktioniert es
dann nicht was falsch gelaufen dass man
also wenn man seine ärztin nicht mit der
ausreichende schutzkleidung versehen
kann hat man in der bevölkerung das
gefühl dass da dinge doch nicht ganz
optimal laufen also das ist das was ich
heute was wir heute nicht mache ich
zumindest nicht also jetzt sagen wir
sparen kritiker irgendwas aber nach
vorne blickend also
sag ich mal wo wir jetzt in der
diskussion aus meiner sicht sehen also
kinder jetzt noch zu testen also um zu
wissen wie viele kinder sind infiziert
hatte ich nach wie vor für mich die
nummer zwei ist es wichtig es wird
richtig lange dauern bis man sagen mal
zentren hat wo man testen kann
die ausgerüstet sind über die ja
trotzdem jetzt mit dem aufbau beginnen
das stimmt einfach ich bin ja der
optimist und sage ich hoffe sie haben
nicht so viele fälle aber einfach
ausgesetzt durch jetzt anfangen also
wird jetzt damit anfangen würde nicht
die partie also sagen mal guten sagen
mal schutzanzüge und masken verschwenden
für eine geringe wahrscheinlichkeit dass
da was ist sondern hast du dich schon
wird wird damit dieses anfang einfach
ausgedruckt und nummer drei also bei den
großveranstaltungen rechtskonservativer
das sind so die drei sachen und was
gewesen ist also dass da müssen andere
das ist also dass es nicht das gehört
hier nicht meine sache ich trotzdem
gerne noch fragen einreise stopps das
gibt länder die da doch deutlich
restriktiver sind und es gibt auch teile
jetzt in der politischen opposition die
auch nach mehr durchgreifen in dieser
frage stellen wird das aus ihrer sicht
zum teil instrumentalisiert und auch ein
bisschen benutzt oder wäre das was wo
sie sagen da können wir schon hinkommen
das kann schon sein dass das sinnvoll
sein wird da wird nicht ihre mahnung
interessieren aber ich erhalte von den
ein hase stopps jetzt nichts muss ich
offen sagen es sei denn sie haben mal
das sind leute die auf hochrisiko
gebieten kommen
mit dem sind wir ja auch im direkten
kontakt und das ist ganz klar die drei
zum beispiel regionen in norditalien die
also wie wir sozusagen hart sind also
sehr stark betroffen ist klar ein
anderer lage da wird ja nicht hinreißen
da würde ich auch sagen mal vom
auswärtigen amt eine klare
wahlempfehlung aussprechen nicht
hinreißen da wurde ich habe also würde
ich da ein bisschen härter auftreten das
ist derzeit machen aber gleichzeitig was
zu den einreise über die bei uns also
sondern allgemein dass man ganze länder
jetzt sperrt so zu sein heutiger
amerikaners gemacht das ist blöd also
länder ist das tempo
man muss vielleicht nicht so viel zurück
gehen die frage ist ja ich war ja einer
der wenigen die gesagt haben wir sollten
wir sollten kontrollen an den flughäfen
machen für diese krisenregion
später dann inzwischen haben ein paar
mehr warum bin ich der meinung dass man
gesundheitskontrollen machen soll bei
der einreise erstens durch die fiber
tests erwischt man einen teil der
patienten
das gegenargument war immer vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium dass sie
gesagt haben ja erwischen da auf keinen
fall alle es ist aber so dass sie
ungefähr ein drittel kriegen durch die
fibaa checks das ist so ungefähr
standard und zwar genau die die
besonders schwer krank sind und die auch
mit sicherheit starke virus ausscheider
sind das heißt es ist schon mal eine
wertvolle beute wenn sie die erwischen
und die anderen zwei drittel die ihnen
bei der einreisekontrolle durch die
lappen gehen
die beraten sehr individuell denen sagen
sie du solltest auf das achten du kommst
aus einer krisenregion vermeide enge
kontakte und ähnliches das ist meines
erachtens extrem wertvoll sie denken an
die wenn man denkt an die chinesin die
in münchen da versehentlich ihre
kollegen bei einem autozulieferer
infiziert hat die hat ja allen die hand
gegeben die hat keinen mundschutz
getragen wahrscheinlich zu hause in
shanghai würde sie den fragen wollt ihr
da zur mode fast gehört hat das nicht
gemacht und hat obwohl sie die ganze
zeit sich fiebrig gefühlt hat und
nebenbei fiebermittel genommen hat wenn
man der bei der einreisekontrolle ins
gewissen geredet hätte bin ich absolut
sicher hätte die sich anders verhalten
und werden vielleicht diese erste
infektionskette schon vermeiden können
also deshalb bin ich für solche
maßnahmen und die haben so lange einen
sinn wie sie im ausland deutlich mehr
fälle haben als im inland also wenn sie
gefahr eines 1 reihe durch einen
einreisenden wesentlich höher ist als
durch einen inlands person
ehrlich gesagt das wird sich in den
nächsten wochen langsam angleichen im
moment sagen wir ja norditalien aber
demnächst wird wahrscheinlich ihre
heimat ins rheinland dann auch so ein
hotspot sein wo man sagt jeder der aus
dem rheinland kommt ist gefährlich und
deshalb nachher desinfiziert also es ist
so dass wir das wir natürlich irgendwann
in der situation sind wir im inland so
viele fälle haben dass die
einreisekontrolle eigentlich keinen sinn
mehr hat das doch weit wir noch nicht
aber das wäre ja dann direkt die nächste
frage also dass angedeutet hat dass
augen halte ich überhaupt nichts von das
ist aber jetzt ist es so wir haben zwei
stufen der epidemiologe
wir haben drei stufen der
epidemiologischen solchen bekämpfung die
erste stufe ist dass sie
einreisekontrollen machen das hat man ja
nicht gemacht die zweite stufe ist das
was ich gerade kurz erwähnt habe die art
die infektionskette früh identifizieren
und eliminieren durch isolation und
quarantäne das nennen wir das tempo auf
austreten wie eine zigarette die dritte
stufe ist dieses abregeln das machen sie
als verzweiflungstat wenn ihnen gar
nichts anderes mehr einfällt dann das
nennt man cordon sanitaire ein
französisches wort was bedeutet dass
stellen sie sich mal vor in norditalien
50.000 leute auf der einen seite fängt
die polizei an das durchzuziehen was
machen denn die leute auf der anderen
seite die versuchen so schnell wie
möglich da raus zu kommen in johann in
china war es so dass fast die hälfte der
einwohner von 11 millionen abgebaut sind
bevor der kreis geschlossen war und in
norditalien also noch nicht dümmer als
die chinesen das heißt also die wissen
dann da jetzt muss ich hier raus dann
sitze ich in so einem quarantäne lager
mit lauter kranken
hier sehen sie das doch wer das denkt
ich bin dagegen dass zu machen wie ich
auch sagt also wenn sie sagen wir eine
pandemie käme und wir hätten klarer
hotspots was ja sagen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt weder der fahrer ist noch
absehbar dann kommt so etwas quasi
automatisch war das in pannen gebiet
plänen und beschrieben ist wie das geht
und dann bringt das über das auch etwas
ich glaube übrigens dass das vorgehen
damit habe ich mich sehr intensiv
beschäftigt in hahn
das war nicht in jeder hinsicht richtig
in der oberliga nicht in den sinn das
war schon sehr stark in deutschland
denkbar woanders wieder aufgestellt der
auf jeden fall der so dass wir wenn wir
das müssten würden das macht dann ist ja
klar ist davon so weit weg also ich
würde jetzt einfach nicht das ist
wirklich das wäre jetzt wirklich also zu
da sind wir da erstens also ist das nur
dann also kommt das kommt wirklich nur
dann wenn sie sehr viele fälle haben die
sind aber nicht über das ganze land
verteilt dass wieder zwei bedienungen
wir haben deshalb nicht sehr viele fälle
sondern wir sind jetzt noch in der lage
sehr viele fälle zu verhindern
mit den maßnahmen über die wir eben
gesprochen haben und zum zweiten wenn
wir sehr viele verleiten da wäre es sehr
unwahrscheinlich in deutschland dass die
sich auf eine region verteilen
warum weil wir nicht die
bevölkerungsdichte erreichen die in der
aus
in der region wo sie sind china
losgegangen ist also zu sehen ist daher
in deutschland ist die bevölkerung
gleichmäßiger verteilt und sie haben
daher also die wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
dass das einmal so ein spot ist wenn das
so etwas gebe in dem sie nur dann haben
die gleichen regeln und ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass die arbeit die in
china geleistet wurde und dass die der
ganzen welt sagte geschenkt hat der
ganzen welt das war eine sehr starke
leute die wir nicht genutzt haben es war
einfach dass man es war eine sehr starke
oft muss man einfach sagen also was zum
beispiel zu wenig beachtet wird
die chinesen haben dann nicht nur das
abgeregelt sondern die haben 40.000
fachkräfte aus ganz china in die region
gebracht zum teil sehr gut angeleitet
der leute die vor ort dort unterwegs
gewesen sind wie sie es nicht so positiv
wie sehr laut aber es ist so also wie
auch normal dass in china was auch immer
das in china bewirkt hat müssen wir
überlegen was wir in deutschland
sinnvoll und ich glaube man muss
folgendes beachten der der
psychologische faktor so eine große zahl
von menschen quasi einzuschließen führt
doch zu einer situation dass diejenigen
die außerhalb dieses gürtels dieses
sperrgürtel sind das die mit er kriegen
durch die medien wie es dazu gibt in
italien ist im moment so fast alle
neuerkrankungen deutlich fast alle bei
der größte teil der neuerkrankungen auch
der todesfälle ist in diesem
abgesperrten gebiet das lesen die
anderen auch und dann sagen die ok jetzt
habe ich seit heute morgen husten gehen
sie dann wenn sie husten haben wirklich
hin zu den behörden an sagen ich will
jetzt auch in so ein gebiet oder ich
will dass mein dorf auch noch damit rein
genommen würden ich glaube dass ich da
war das so aber erinnern dass in europa
ist das so ich glaube
wissen sie die meisten sind ja nicht
krank die meisten sind ja völlig gesund
ich glaube dass die hand die
verschränkung effekt einer solchen einer
solchen
maßnahme ist enorm ich habe auch eben
gesagt das wird in deutschland nicht
kommen die wahrscheinlichkeit also dass
es kommt ist nicht so groß sei es
gedankt und schön aus den gründen dass
wir diese großen fallzahlen also mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit hier in
deutschland nicht sehen werden dass sie
langsamer los wir können auch jetzt noch
viel machen wir haben zeit geworden
wir können noch viel machen wir haben im
moment haben wir super viel einfluss das
ganz toll also wir haben noch sehr viel
einfluss auf den verlauf und das hat die
chinesin ja nicht die sind wir haben am
anfang den fehler gemacht dass das lange
zeit hätte ich jetzt noch ein wenig
die kriegt aber in china dass ihr das
ist darum haben wir ja auch das ist also
nicht alles ist in china also richtig
gelaufen
aber wenn wir so etwas hätten also da
würde ich den idealismus und auch die
ehrlichkeit der menschen nicht
unterschätzen dass die dann sagen okay
also ich lasse mich testen ich bleibe
dann zu hause die maßen isolierungen
sind hat man zu hause war und china so
von daher das glaube ich dann schon
aber egal das ist überhaupt nicht
wichtig zu diskutieren weil erstens dass
hamann ich zweitens die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass bekommen ist
gering
und zum dritten was viel wichtiger ist
wir haben noch riesige spielraum gibt es
ja auch uns also wir können also dass
und das kann noch getan werden dass
karmann abwenden ich bin ein punkt noch
wichtig es gibt ja so ein bisschen
gerade in sozialen medien die vermutung
ist wird uns nicht alles gesagt oder
bestimmte fallzahlen kommen nicht so an
wie sie eigentlich sind
da würd mich nochmal ihre einschätzung
interessiert die sozialen medien sind in
dieser epidemie in dieser beginnenden
pandemie ein neues phänomen geworden
das hatten wir bei den letzten noch
nicht weil die früher noch nicht so
stark waren dass es so dass tatsächlich
durch diese diese verteilung von
informationen dass jeder so in seiner
eigenen blase lebt und dadurch dass es
keine gemeinsamen anerkannten
informationen mehr gibt hat das eine
eigendynamik bekommen mit
verschwörungstheorien ich habe also
ernsthafte fragen von chinesischen
journalisten bekommen
ob das sein kann dass das virus in
amerika hergestellt wurde um die
chinesische rasse zu bekämpfen gezielt
und die haben da auch literatur dazu
dann raus gezogen die das angeblich
belegt ich bin sogar so weit gegangen
jetzt angefangen anzufangen selber zu
twittern zu dem thema aber ich gesagt
man muss in diesen sozialen bereich
denen irgendwas einlegen müsse da nicht
noch mehr entgegen du würdest
der soll es ganz schwierig weil die
leute versuchen sich die information
heraus die sie haben wollen
es hat schon eine masochistische tendenz
dass es uns will brauchen was am
gruseligsten ist gefällt ihnen und wird
weiter geliked oder weiter geschickt und
da kommen sie mit so einer langweiligen
information
wieso einem sag ich mal netten
beschwichtigungsversuch von herrn
lauterbach dass er sagt ich glaube ich
glaube es wird nicht so schlimm da das
ist nicht so interessant jemand der sagt
das wird richtig krass der kriegt
vielmehr der krieg da viel mehr
aufmerksamkeit das war jetzt nicht gegen
sie sowohl denn die em ist leider schon
mehr weniger am schluss der sendung ich
würde noch eine sache interessieren was
glauben sie wann sind wir dann kann man
absehen wann wir so ein bisschen mehr
über den berg sind oder lässt sich das
jetzt schlechterdings noch gar nicht
prophezeien also über den berg so lange
nicht am anfang also wer spricht warum
über den moerser also über den berg
insofern dass sich ja doch einige
experten sagen dass es sobald es wärmer
wird es dich dass zumindest nicht mehr
weiter beschleunigen wird und da habe
ich aber die frage ist was vor dem
sommer noch passiert es ist klar dass es
im sommer dass das wäre das virus würde
sich überhaupt nicht an die spielregeln
halten wenn es im sommer nicht
wenigstens ein bisschen schwächer würde
so an runter und das wäre echt unfair
sage ich mal als virologe wenn es
komplett neu wäre
und bis dahin müssen wir das beste
daraus machen und ich kann nicht oft
genug sagen wir haben einfach eine
exponentielle funktion und wenn wir
jetzt nicht unmittelbar was tun dann
haben wir eben so viele fälle unter
umständen dass unser system an die
grenzen kommen könnte wenn wir jetzt
entschlossen handeln und spät aber doch
das passiert was notwendig ist da stimme
ich ein lauterbach zu dann haben wir
noch eine gute chance dass in
deutschland in einem bereich zu halten
dass unser gesundheitssystem das
irgendwie abfängt
dank ihnen beiden für die diskussion ist
glaube es gibt noch viele themen aber es
wird sicher auch nicht die letzte
sendung sein
erstmal habe ich wahrgenommen dass es
keinen grund zur panik gibt dass viele
maßnahmen schon auf dem richtigen weg
sind und das ist sag ich mal in der
herangehensweise inwiefern man kinder
vielleicht noch stärker in den blick
nimmt noch unterschiedliche meinungen
gibt und auch bezüglich von absage von
großveranstaltungen erstmal vielen
vielen dank ihnen auch das zuschauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]